it is easy to ignore the main story of
watch dogs legion and just go down the
rabbit hole of chasing new recruits to
add to the deadset collective
in this video we're gonna briefly show
you some of our favorite characters that
we found so far and give you a quick
breakdown of how to collect powerful
eccentric and useful recruits to make
the most out of your team of
anti-fascist hackers
i'll command you
so how does recruiting work for starters
nearly every character you come across
in london is a potential recruit even
the members of the private military that
have taken over the city you don't
necessarily have to find people if you
don't want to
the game does give you a steady stream
of team members as you complete missions
and liberate areas of london
like this super spy who owns a car that
cloaks and fires missiles
my starting character was a kicking
granny that could camouflage like the
predator
but much of the fun in legion comes from
finding random people that join the
cause
as you go through the city as you wander
london you can scan people to see what
their traits are take it from us
there are some good reads in there if
you see someone you like first make sure
they approve of dead sec with this handy
thumbs up
thumbs down indicator if they don't like
deadsec you'll have to build up enough
tech points to unlock the deep profiler
honestly if recruiting is your thing the
deep profiler is a must
it also gives you second chances if you
blow recruiting missions
once you've added someone to your
potential recruits list you'll need to
do a mission or two to gain their favor
missions we've seen so far are pretty
varied but can involve a rescue a
delivery or just getting rid of bad
folks
the first recruits you meet will
typically have two traits and some of
them are pretty hilarious
seriously there are people who can't
stealth because they far too much
while the game randomly generates people
for you to recruit there are archetypes
that they fall under
for example if you recruit a
construction worker they're able to
casually walk around any private
construction site without triggering
suspicion unless they get very close to
a guard
other recruits are expert hackers and
can nab access keys that open doors from
great distances
there are a series of fighting pits
around london and you'll definitely want
to go find someone with fighting skills
like the ability to deliver staggering
counter punches
the more pit bites you win the more
brawlers you add to your roster
as you progress in the game you'll start
to see more powerful recruits
indicated by a colored circle over their
head these higher level recruits will
have multiple skills
so definitely stop and check them out
but the best part is finding some really
fun
oddball or unique recruits we've come
across a 70 year old dominatrix that has
a spiked bat
get that stick out of your boogie
a gold painted performance artist you
can collect tips while at work
a cosplayer and a street magician who
can hypnotize people into a frenzy
zombie apocalypse what are you doing
there are also some less
practical skills like dancing for small
amounts of currency and
getting drunk before a fight
all of those paints are hitting me the
more we wander london the more
interesting characters we're coming
across
hopefully we gave you a quick idea of
what recruiting's like and we definitely
want to hear about the weird people you
run into
there's a lot more to talk about so head
on over to gamespot to watch more videos
including a whole lot of next-gen
coverage thanks for watching
you